welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this episode
were breaking down some insane details
in Joker the film has been sweeping the
board recently at award shows and it's
no surprise due to the sheer amount of
love that went to it each scene is
something hidden in it and throughout
this video we're gonna be breaking down
some of the best things that you may
have missed about the movie there will
be heavy spoilers here itself you
haven't seen Joker yet and don't want
anything potentially ruined then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking the video
now let's get into our breakdown of
insane details in Joker Joker sent us
around Arthur flak as he transforms into
the infamous Clown Prince of Crime the
entire piece feels I could count down
towards the ending in which both the
titular character and his polar opposite
Batman are born sometimes in TV shows
and movies when something is counting
down to a specific moment there are
often signifiers put into the background
of scenes this is exemplified in How I
Met Your Mother
in which the show features a number in
every episode counting down to a
specific moment Joker also features a
similar aesthetic throughout the film
and during the movie there's a countdown
from the start all the way to the end
that happens during notable moments in
the movie when Arthur visits his
psychiatrist we can see that the clock
behind him is set to 11 minutes past
11:00 he then mentions being locked up
in the hospital and we get a quick cut
of him in the cells smashing his head
against the wall we can see that the
time on the clock is also set to 11:11
bringing attention to this number before
Joker commits the murder of the three
Wayne employees in the subway we can see
the number 10 behind one of their heads
Arthur chases one of them onto a
platform before shooting them and the
number 9 can be seen everywhere not only
does this indicate the platform number
but also the fact that we are moving
towards something important selfies
apartment is 8 B and we see this both
when he first apparently kisses her and
when we later realize that their
relationship was a fantasy when stealing
the file from the clerk played by Brian
Tyree Henry Arthur runs to stairwell 7
when being chased by policemen later in
the film he boards the train on platform
six and then when they are later killed
the character dances whilst holding up
five fingers backstage and the Murray
Franklin show Arthur is in room 404 and
we can also see the number four in the
background during the exchange on the
show and during his rant Arthur is
filmed by camera three and later when
the death of the host breaks it is
reported by his station name to WGC
Gotham it all culminates when Joker
rises at the end and stands in front of
a cinema named ace in the hole an ace
can represent eleven all one in cards
and to me this also signifies a deck of
cards of which the Joker is also a
member similar to ace in the hole
Joker's Wilders as saying in cards but
that may be a reach okay okay it's a
reach I admit it Arthur losing his grip
on his sanity is also demonstrated with
the characters makeup throughout the
film initially it starts off quite
stable and ordered but by the end of the
movie he has walked which cements his
fractured psyche the makeup pattern
itself is actually extremely similar to
the design that serial killer John Wayne
Gacy used to Don when performing as a
clown Gacy murder at least thirty three
boys are men between 1972 and 1978 the
name he gave his alter ego was Pogo the
clown and Arthur later performs at a
comedy club which also just so happens
to be called pogos Arthur's mental state
slippin is also demonstrated by the way
that he writes in the film typically the
character writes with his right hand
however when writing a joke about mental
illness he uses his left which could
indicate the darker side of his
personality is slowly starting to take
over in medieval times and even today in
certain cultures being left-handed is
sometimes associated with being evil and
this could highlight his transition
jokers joke book itself also sets up
certain things that happen in the film
when taking notes on the comedy routine
he writes one about slicking his hair
back and then does this later when he
performs he also has a joke about
someone who died on the sidewalk whilst
others walked right over him and later
he references this as a true story on
the murray Franklin show indicating that
he is an unreliable narrator speaking of
unreliable narrators his mother plays a
big part in the film and claims several
times throughout the movie that Thomas
Wayne is Arthur's father Arthur clearly
has fantasies about people being his dad
so naturally he gravitates towards this
when talking to Rand Ola the character
says that Arthur is like a son to him
before giving him a gun and we later
learn that the scene may have been
different in reality due to Randall's
claims that Arthur instead tried to bite
from him when imagining he's on the
Murray Franklin show he dreams that
Murray says he'd give it all up for a
son like him and thus the Thomas Waynes
statement becomes his obsession but are
they actually related well the movie
paints it out that penny flack was an
obsessed ex-employee of Wayne's that
went insane and abused him as a child
she tried to blackmail Thomas at several
points and he always disputed that he
was Arthur's father in the film before
punching Arthur in the face much like
his son would do many times in the
future who had given the notion that
Arthur was actually adopted it really
can go either way but I'll just go into
the main signifiers for and against are
this true parentage okay so in the film
both Alfred and Thomas state that penny
tried to blackmail a family and this is
added credence by Thomas who says to
Arthur what do you want is it money the
fact that he comes out with this
straightaway indicates that penny has
tried to get him to cough up the dough
before and thus he's expecting it from
Arthur Thomas says that she was crazy
and we do see in the film that she was
sent to Arkham for apparently abusing
Arthur as a child however it is possible
at due to the scandal it would create
Thomas covered up his illegitimate child
and had Penny sent to the asylum so that
no one would ever believe her variously
penny and Joker both share the same
condition known as narcissistic
personality disorder or NPD for short
people with this mental illness have
exaggerated feelings of self-importance
and need for admiration and a lack of
empathy this could show that she abused
him as a child but it does pretty much
rule out the adoption the condition is
hereditary and therefore it is very
unlikely that Arthur and Penny have this
and aren't related the claims that penny
is evil can be disputed in the film by
the fact that when we are with her all
we see is a kind and gentle woman
whereas Thomas comes across well as a
bit of a jerk
the movie carries the theme of the rich
dumping on the poor and this could also
be exemplified by Arthur's father
when Arthur grabs the adoption papers
they are actually crisper and seemed to
be slightly different to the rest of the
paperwork in the file which could
indicate a forgery when arthur meets
bruce at the gates of wayne manor the
two are both wearing similar color
schemes and clothing they both have tan
coats white tops and black pants on and
not only does this show the difference
in class as Bruce's are pristine whereas
others aren't there are also indications
in the choice of actors chosen the boy
who plays Bruce also played a younger
version Joaquin Phoenix in the film you
were never really here
and this may have been intentionally
done by Phillips due to the fact that
they look slightly alike a nurse could
share a kinship there's also the photo
of penny with the initials TW on the
back which indicates at one point that
Thomas could have been attracted to her
we see Penny's handwriting earlier in
the movie and this is different to the
style written on the back of the picture
watching this scene personally I got the
feeling that Joker knew it was true from
this moment but he justs crumpled up the
paper because he didn't want to face
what he'd done the movie has a thematic
arc about Arthur searching for a father
and in doing this Bruce loses his own
and this is almost poetic in some ways
but yeah make up your own mind on that
Philips also packed the movie with
references to other films and work the
text during the intro and the ending of
the movie is the same font in Citizen
Kane down to the words the end Murray
Franklin also has a guest on a show
called Ethan chase who's starring in a
movie named American playboy Bruce Wayne
is often referred to as a playboy
American could be a reference to
American Psycho starring Christian Bale
who also famously played Batman the name
Ethan chases also the name of Zach
Galifianakis is character in due date
which was also directed by todd phillips
the curtains on the murray franklin show
are similar to The Tonight Show when
Johnny Carson hosted the Charlie Chaplin
film modern times that is shown in the
movie was a commentary on the Great
Depression and how difficult it was to
live during it this mirrors the poor
struggling in Gotham and how the rich
seemed to be laughing at them Arthur is
also seen watching shall we dance which
was also a hit during the Great
Depression
whilst watching this Arthur seems to
mimic taxi driver in trying to act tough
to himself in his apartment the film
references the King of Comedy movie
throughout well well everything but
there's also several references to
Batman properties as you would expect a
painting that Arthur has in his
apartment actually appears in Batman
1989 during the art gallery scene in
which Jack Nicholson quote-unquote
improves the paintings when Arthur goes
to see Bruce at Wayne Manor
we see a shot where he slides down a
pole this is very similar to how the
character would in the 1966 show
starring Adam West and Burt Ward Gary
and Randall are supposed to mirror the
iconography of Joker's henchmen with one
of them being a fat and tall giant
whereas the other is a small [ __ ]
there are also three Joker stories at
the movie references the first is Alan
was The Killing Joke in which the Joker
initially starts as a stand-up comedian
the book showcased our one bad day could
send someone over the edge and this
definitely provides a metaphor for the
film the second is on a beautiful
summer's day he was which was about the
Joker living with his father though it
is his mother in the movie in the work
he spends the majority of his time
scrolling jokes into a notebook the
third is the Dark Knight Returns which
has the Joker appear on the dave
endochrine show and murder the host
guests and audience the movie opens on a
news report which also feels similar to
the aforementioned comic book which also
opens with bulletins similar to the work
it also has news reports in its sprawled
across like panels from a comic book
during the film we see a sign for
Robinson Park at the ninth Avenue subway
stop and this location is also mentioned
in the Batman book year one as we
mentioned earlier Joker sits in the
dressing room 404 which is also the
issue that Yael once started at the
diner that Arthur takes Sophie to is on
Jerome Avenue and this is a reference to
Jerome Valeska who was the twin brother
of Jeremiah who became the Joker in the
TV show Gotham in a deleted scene
Arthur was seen outside a mural at red
amusement mile and this is a reference
to the carnival section of Gotham that
the Clown Prince of Crime used as his
home the ambulance at the end that
crashes into the cop car had also been
redesigned to look more Joker esque
however this was cut from the film and I
really wish they had a boat in Thomas
says that anyone who hides behind the
mask is a coward and this is of course a
reference to Batman and I know that's an
obvious one author's social worker is
called there bro Kane which is a nod to
one of the creators of Batman at Bob
Kane the font of the Murray Franklin
show is the same as the font used in
Batman the Animated Series and the back
drop of the skyline is also from the
cartoon the movie also has several
scenes that mirror one another and
showed the evolution of certain
characters and the opening of the film
arthur is attacked in an alleyway and
this eventually leads to him becoming
the Joker this is reflected in the
attack on the Wayne's which later
happens in an alleyway and also sends
Bruce on the way to becoming Batman
after Arthur is fired from his job he
dances whilst walking down the stairs
this almost indicates his descent into
madness and this style of dancing down
some stairs appears later in the movie
when the character has fully embraced
his new persona super rats are mentioned
early on and these actually pop up
whilst Arthur is making a phone call at
one point in the movie and then later
during the death of the Wayne's when
practicing for the Murray show you can
see that Arthur has made his own mug and
written on it in magic marker to try and
recapture the look of the set and
finally is a theory that the entire
movie is all in Joker's head this is
exemplified by the fact that when Arthur
is in the psychiatrist office the clock
can be seen as being set at 11 minutes
past 11:00 when describing the hospital
Arthur bangs his head against the door
we can also see that the clock is set to
the exact same time when Arthur goes to
punch out the time is also set to 11
minutes past 11:00 which indicates that
Arthur is actually in the hospital at
the end imagining this entire story and
when he bangs his head against the glass
it snaps him out a bit for a brief
moment Arthur does say at one point that
he never really existed and we know that
the character is prone to fantasies it
is possible that due to his lack of not
having a father he imagined that he took
the father away from his worst enemy in
the King James Bible chapter and verse
11 11 the following passage can be found
therefore thus saith the Lord behold I
will bring evil upon them which they
shall not be able to escape and no they
shall cry unto me I will not hearken
unto them this pretty much sounds like
it is referring to the Joker directly
who is very much getting revenge on his
city and people that he views as
wronging him those who've seen the movie
us by Jordan Peele may also remember
that 11:11 pops up throughout that film
and it is referring to the same thing
that I believe that the Joker movie is
hinting at whilst Phillips and Phoenix
are both deny that there is any
connection it is fun to tie these things
together
and the clown company that jokah works
at is called hahas and that's our entire
list I had a blast making this video and
I hope you had fun watching it we're
gonna try and do a video like this every
week so make sure you drop a comment on
what movie you'd like to see me cover
next time
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the tidbits so make sure you leave
your thoughts on them too if you missed
our video last week then I'll leave that
linked at the end as we go over some
insane details in adventures end game
and a guarantee there will be some in
there that you haven't heard before you
want to support the channel and get to
see content early then please consider
clicking the join button below you can
also come chat to a set of discord link
in the description or a definition
whitey on Twitter that's the best way to
keep up to date with the show and
hopefully I see over there very soon
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this I've been definition you've been
the best I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you